français mes chers compatriotes le virus
circule en france à une vitesse que même
les prévisions les plus pessimistes
n'avait pas anticipé j'ai décidé qu'il
fallait retrouver à partir de vendredi
le confinement qui a stoppé le virus les
commerces qui ont été définies au
printemps comme non essentiels les
établissements recevant du public
notamment les bars et restaurants seront
fermées comme au printemps le quoiqu'il
en voilà donc on prépare tous les
journaux petit sachet avec serviette
couverts en plastique fins reporter
c'est vraiment un crève coeur de
travailler comme ça moi je n'aime pas du
tout mettre ça dans des gamelles tout
tout tout mélanger tout va il ya c'est
un peu gênant la vente à emporter c'est
la seule solution laisser aux
restaurateurs pour limiter les pertes et
à l'amertume de la présentation en sacs
plastiques s'ajoute la frustration de ne
pas pouvoir faire entendre sa colère
depuis châteaudun petite ville
tranquille de 14 mille habitants bien
sûr qu'on est prêts à manifester mais on
n'a pas déjà c'est un vrai on n'a pas
les moyens
c'est
le peu qu'on fait ou je suis obligé de
travailler tous les jours pour faire du
der par emporter le peu qu'on fait on a
besoin d'être là on n'a pas le temps
d'allumer vais manifester si je pouvais
je le ferai mais malheureusement c'est
pour c'est pas possible
le couple qui gère la petite vitesse a
survécu au premier confinement en
utilisant toute sa trésorerie
mais depuis les échéances se sont
accumulés une dizaine de clients en
moyenne commander sa chaire pas qu'on
d'habitude on compte 35 couverts par
service
alors pour tenir il faut trouver des
solutions
je travaille en extérieur sur un
chantier où je fais des ménages donc
pour rendre des appartements propres le
restaurant peut pas subvenir à nos
besoins
le peu qu'ils rentrent au niveau du
restaurant ne fournira pas du tout pour
pouvoir les factures donc moi fallait
que je trouve un travail à côté de façon
à pouvoir nous vivre rires à côté il y à
l'aide directe de l'état plafonné à 1500
euros et le fonds de solidarité
mais pour ceux qui ont de grosses
charges de loyer comme le gérant de ce
parc de jeux dont le chiffre d'affaires
a diminué de moitié en 2020 ça ne suffit
plus la question se pose pour moi de
savoir si je vais vendre si je vais
continuer pour l'instant je survis tout
est fait tout est fait pour les employés
ils ont un chômage partiel tout ça mais
nous les patrons on a que dalle
on n'a rien excusez moi n'a rien et rien
n'est prévu pour nous parce que nous
deux patrons ont filmé notre famille
aussi il n'y a pas que les autres pays
qui font vivre non février nos familles
donc on est en haut des trucs précaires
comme ça on est encore plus précaire que
les employés
combien de boutiques seront obligés de
baisser définitivement le rideau à
châteaudun dans quelques mois
la question inquiète le maire qui dès
l'annoncé du repos finement a pris un
arrêté autorisant tous les commerces à
rester ouverts malgré tout rapidement
invalidée par le tribunal administratif
il signifiait aussi que tout en haut les
décideurs aurait pu s'y prendre
autrement on a l'impression de payer
pour les grandes villes et grandes
métropoles
on n'a pas les avantages et en plus on
nous demande les inconvénients il faut
qu'ils se rendent compte qu'on n'est pas
aux galeries lafayette
encore une fois il peut rentrer 15 à 20
personnes dans une journée dans un
commerce à bonneval abrous à châteaudun
à quoi à la commune nouvelle d'art ou
par exemple et donc ya pas de risque à
rentrer à 10h15 quelqu'un à 10h48 ya pas
de risque en plus il ya des protocoles
ce n'est pas ici que le virus se
transpose tout au long du mois de
novembre la clientèle n'a cessé de
défiler sur le pas de porte de la
librairie du coin pour ce secteur
l'activité a été soutenue par un élan de
solidarité nationale portés par des
figures intellectuelles mais
habituellement 40% du chiffre d'affaires
est réalisé sur les deux derniers mois
de l'année
hélas les ventes provoquée par le hasard
des rencontres et les conseils des
libraires ont disparu travail mais c'est
pas notre travail ont fait un travail
mais pas le nôtre
on n'est pas ouvert non des horaires de
retrait pour si vous avez des commandes
ou des titres que vous souhaitez on peut
vous les fournir quand même
physiquement c'est assez c'est assez
compliqué à gérer ça s'arrête jamais on
on travaille beaucoup beaucoup pour pour
beaucoup moins de deux chiffres
concrètement nos charges à payer donc il
faut y penser
cliquez collecter évoluer sur internet
transiter vers le monde d'après dans ce
magasin de vêtements on a bien entendu
est appliqué les consignes du
gouvernement met en situation de
confinement
tous les commerces ne sont pas égaux le
click and collect par rapport à mon
activité
ça fonctionne pas du tout voir ce que
voilà moi j'ai une activité de
l'équipement de la personne magasin
plutôt traditionnelle les gens voilà ma
clientèle ne l'achète pas sur internet
ils veulent venir nous voir veulent
notre conseil va l'essayer
donc non ça n'a pas fonctionné du tout
j'ai je me suis inscrite sur la plate
forme qui a été mise en place faire mes
courses point fr j'ai mis tous les
articles et pris fin j'ai fait tout bien
comme il faut mais j'ai zéro retour on a
presque le sentiment qu'il ya une
volonté politique de
de mettre à mort le petit commerce voilà
c'est peut-être un peu brutal mais c'est
franchement ce que je pense et ce qu'on
ait beaucoup à penser s'il consomme
beaucoup moins dans les commerces de
proximité en période de confinement les
français n'ont pas cessé de consommer
pour autant à mesure que les emplois
pérennes de l'ancien monde disparaissent
l'économie s'adapte pour faire face au
boom des livraisons la poste a recruté
pour la fin de l'année
9000 cdd dont 400 dans la région en
général cette taille est collé elle
démarre plutôt deuxième quinzaine de
novembre avec un pic au black friday
là pour le coup cette augmentation est
connue elle a commencé dès le
confinement dès la première semaine
d'octobre on navigue déjà un solide
frémissement et la deuxième semaine
d'octobre on avait battu notre record
annuel selon la poste le volume du
commerce en ligne a atteint depuis
l'épidémie
un niveau qui n'était pas prévue avant
trois ans d vous quasiment vide
une main d'oeuvre précaire transportent
les colis du hangar à la boîte aux
lettres l'économie du sans contact a su
saisir l'opportunité pour accélérer une
position déjà planifié dans le monde
d'avant